you look amazing tell me about just a
moment ago you had that moment with your
sister here on the carpet tell me about
that moment oh my gosh I'm so happy that
my sister's here it makes me so happy
that she's here it makes my whole day
and she'll be actually seeing the film
for the first time tonight so once I get
her stamp of approval I feel good she
told me she's your number one fan nobody
better even think about it this is who
she is she is for sure it's a big night
for my sister how excited are you can
you not tell I've been trying to not cry
every time I think about it and I'm the
only one who hasn't seen it because I've
been on tour and they had the early
screenings and I just I gotta get
tissues with me Chloe you're gonna cry
you're gonna cry I gotta get tissues
with me I'm so freaking proud of her
I've been seeing Billboards and
magazines of her everywhere and I am
just so freaking proud and we get to be
here now
I'm just so proud of her for believing
in herself and finding her inner
strength and taking on such an iconic
role and being so phenomenal at it so
what did you think when you saw those
videos of those little girls be it just
crying and being emotional and being so
awestruck by the vision of her yes even
just talking about it I get chills to
know that all of those beautiful girls
will be able to see proper
representation whether you're black or
white or anything like that you'll be
able to look at my sister and say I can
be anything that I want to be no matter
what the world tells me is acceptable
and there could not be a more perfect
area
I'm so excited and I know I wondered
like how because I'm sure she really
went through a process I mean becoming a
Disney princess to be honest she didn't
really have to do much training for that
like she's always been like that sweet
like
like that's Holly that's Hallie so the
Stars aligned I feel like all her life
she's been preparing for this role y'all
get you a hype woman like Chloe find you
somebody for one fan I will beat out
anybody try me
foreign